KATIE COURIC: As more
young people like David
hole up in their rooms
with their devices,
studies show a generation
delaying adulthood.
Fewer get driver's licenses,
have after school jobs,
or date.
But most alarming, the suicide
rate for girls ages 15 to 19
doubled between 2007 and 2015.
Dr. Larry Rosen, a
leading psychologist,
is especially concerned
about what all this tech
is doing to developing brains.
LARRY ROSEN: We know what the
blue light does to their brain.
Night after night, it leaves
these little molecules
called beta amyloids.
And they build into plaques.
And when they look at the
brains of Alzheimer's patients,
they have a lot of
plaque in their brains.
And I think that we're
heading toward a major problem
as these kids who
have been using phones
for the last 10
years start to get
into their 20s, 30s, and 40s.
And I think we're going
to start seeing a lot
of memory problems coming up.
KATIE COURIC: Wow.
That's pretty scary.
Tech is not only
affecting our brains.
It's also affecting
our creativity.
LARRY ROSEN: When you
are being creative
or your mind is wandering or
you're dreaming or daydreaming,
a different part of
your brain is activated.
Part of what we're doing to
ourselves, as well as our kids,
is that we're not allowing
enough of that time.
Because it's so easy to
just pull out your phone
and check the news or whatever.
It doesn't matter.
It stifles your ability
to live within boredom.
And boredom is important,
because boredom then clicks
in the creative activities.
We don't allow ourselves
to get bored anymore.